hello and welcome to this video playing
Allah cos I could have tried something
different actually but okay that's what
I am pretty often things yeah wow this
is by his standards very aggressive
attain usually goes be should be seven
eight
I think this is not very well timed
actually
so if I go 95 am I not winning some
stuff what some other
I mean I'm discovering on his rope here
anyway 95 he can take 95 he were
probably well 95 I can actually take
take Knight f6 yeah that that fits upon
probably hmm I wonder ever have
something better that rook looks so
funky
I can also castle him he might take it
okay let's do this 95 it doesn't feel
like it's the best somehow okay so he
sacrificed the exchange okay
okay about taking them t4 is still
hanging interesting yeah I'm really not
sure this was the right choice 95
who came so I'm going to take now here
and here okay so he doesn't have a
really clear way here to night I have
six maybe I can keep on d4 maybe I
should just take here
it's the relatively simple way of doing
it and now okay rook d7 he's got booked
his seven coming
I'm sure he has a little bit of
compensation him with Bishop f6 you know
take take a 3 goes Bishop b3 that's not
so easy okay I can definitely take one
and now Bishop 34 would be it would be
good look the one I'm losing the a2 upon
I don't want to do that you should to
default would be good
really okay let's do this
I am down to 139 the the biggest problem
yes actually that the time is not good
so he can get into some totally dead
ending here easily and he had a way on
time I should have played a for of
course that was stupid to play for
immediately
maybe I should have played h4 in this
position but okay
Jared's completely completely equal of
course yeah you can cannot do much him
brah our third I will try one little
thing I think the risk is relatively low
here that's kind of surprising that
looks like a pretty awful self of like
why did you love that I King do three
yeah I know I don't have King is seven
mmm okay I have to be quick there
so this is completely frozen now and I
can move the c-pawn soonish that's very
tricky for black I don't see how he
exactly hold that I think you think he's
losing actually I think I promote this
upon yeah going to promote the soup on
it doesn't happen all that often that he
screws up an equal ending black resigns
nice to win it ending against him
once in a while but yeah that's it's
very surprising that this is a total
draw yeah I guess he probably relaxed
too early I mean usually I'll place me
in the ending so probably all you thinks
that I'm such a terrible ending player
that whatever yeah no yeah the opening
is of course looks disastrous but I
didn't quite refute it didn't quite
refute it this is fianchettoed rook the
computer does that and make sense
develop a piece and only then see how
you can do something yeah it's not great
you know if I take this you've got
tremendous compensation here this after
castling a card game there is a maid
threat and the bishop is very strong
castles
and this one yeah that's play-doh I mean
really playable and he also can do that
let the engine recommendation the bishop
here is such a great piece and that is
his fine it was absolutely fun he also
was fine in the game quite quite clearly
this is compensation I was expecting
Bishop f6 here not 96 to be honest but I
mean this is ok he has compensation for
the pony again very very clearly yeah
big stakes yeah now I had to say for
idea on you know a three and then I
should I should have done a four
immediately him here it's it's just it's
equal jack he probably had different
options but you know how did he where
did he screw it up I think this f5 setup
that that really surprised me that he
was going for that this year the said
that really was surprising because you
know it's totally unnecessary you can
with black a thought I thought maybe I'm
wrong but I thought he would play a
bishop to protect f7 and just stop the
pawn with the king so yeah I can also
start with this let's say and keep this
covered and can't go up I have this f3
oops I have this f3 gfy there maybe
ultimately to get an H pawn maybe the
sverige him but he can go here it should
be a draw after that I'm really not sure
that this this feels very problematic to
me from black
yeah but now it's using the engine
controls that I just get get to remove
the see point I have the correct Bishop
people the age porn so let's a
relatively easy win okay guys thanks for
watching